SUDHEERA VANGURI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Document AI
session I am Sudheera Vanguri
and I lead the Document AI
product suite at Google Cloud.
A quick run through
of the agenda
today, I'll be starting with
the challenges and market
opportunities we're seeing in
document processing and dive
into a product overview
of Document AI.
I'll also be sharing
some customer use cases
and some exciting new
announcements in Document AI
solutions.
Following that, my
colleague, Lewis Liu
will unbundle some
of the technologies
we use under the hood.
Let's dive right in.
Nearly all the business
processes today begin, include,
or end with a document.
Most companies are sitting
on a document goldmine.
Think PDFs, emails, customer
feedback, patents, contracts,
technical documents,
sensitive documents, HR files,
and the list goes on.
And these documents are only
going to grow with time.
If you're already trying to
make sense of your documents,
it's likely you're only
scratching the surface.
A lot of these documents
are unstructured,
which can be very time
consuming to process.
What do we mean by
structured and unstructured?
20% of enterprise
data is structured.
Now by structured
data, this can be
human-generated or
machine-generated data
that is highly organized and
formatted to be searchable.
A lot of data analytics
tools out there
can be used to process
structured data.
However, 80% of enterprise data
today is still unstructured.
This unstructured data is
in the form of free form
text such as written
documents, emails, comments.
And the data analytics
tools out there
to process this unstructured
data are still very nascent.
Document processing has become
increasingly complex with time.
Processes that involve large
volumes of unstructured content
are increasing day by day.
For instance, top
tier logistics firms
process over 50,000
bills of ladings per day.
The diversity of incoming
data spans a variety
of doc types and formats.
For instance, the average
mortgage application
today exceeds over 350 pages and
over 60 major document types.
Why is the diversity increasing?
This diversity can
be increasing because
of government regulations,
and as the types of business
relationships and
entity linkages
across various [? all ?]
documents increase with time.
A lot of external
knowledge can also
be associated with a document
in its evaluation process.
For instance,
looking at a document
you may need to know if
this driver's license is
the official Nebraska driver's
license format or not.
Cross linking entities within
various incoming data streams
generates major new value.
And analyzing the semantic
depth of documents
can unlock various
insights within businesses.
However, processing these
documents is quite challenging.
Because of the various document
formats, the manual processes,
the costs of error,
a lot of bad data,
and long processing
times and delays,
businesses are faced with
high costs, lost revenue,
and missed opportunities.
That's where
Document AI comes in.
In a nutshell, Document AI
extracts structured data
from unstructured content.
Document AI enables
businesses to unlock insights
from your documents
with machine learning.
This can enable businesses
to make better decisions
such as analyzing customer
feedback, processing
invoices, or reduced
mortgage processing times.
Document AI can extract as
well as classify information
from unstructured documents.
Document AI within
Google Cloud builds
on top of our computer vision,
natural language, and knowledge
graph technologies.
We have a variety of products
within Google Cloud AI
to meet customers
where they are.
Within Document
AI building blocks
we have a suite of products
under general Document
AI, custom Document AI, and
specialized Document AI.
By general Document
AI, I'm referring
to Google's general OCR models
applied to your content.
Custom Document AI enables
you to train custom models
on your content, to identify
domain specific content tuned
to your own specific
training data.
With specialized
Document AI you can
use Google [? sturdy ?]
models to get out
of the box extraction and
classification for some
of the most common document
types in the world.
Let me unbundle that for
you a little bit more.
With general Document
AI we have our print OCR
and handwriting OCR APIs
that are already in GA.
They support over 200
languages with our print OCR
and over 50 languages
with our handwriting OCR.
These are already available
under the Vision API today.
Recently, we have also
introduced the form parser
API in beta.
And this enables you to
identify special content
such as key value pairs,
tabular content within highly
structured forms.
With custom Document
AI, last year
we went out GA with AutoML Doc
Classification and AutoML Doc
Extraction APIs.
These tools enable you to
provide your own training data
and tune domain specific
content, extraction,
and classification applied to
your own business documents.
We're also introducing custom
form parser APIs in alpha
that can enable you to
extract content provided
a single blank form template.
With our specialized
Document AI suite,
our goal is to catalog
and build dedicated models
for some of the world's
most common document types.
These document models
are highly accurate,
enabling you to classify and
identify specific document
types such as
invoices and receipts
and various other
document types that I
will be talking about shortly.
You can also provide data
validation and knowledge graph
validation against
dates, addresses,
and various [INAUDIBLE]
types that you
find within these documents.
And with this
turnkey capability,
you can apply these models to
do classification and extraction
against your own documents,
high volume documents
as defined within
the business process.
Some examples of our
specialized Document AI models
are the invoice parser APIs
and the receipt parser APIs,
which are now available
in private beta.
Across various industries, such
as retail, financial services,
health care, media and
entertainment, and industrial,
we are seeing customers
use Document AIs in ways
we couldn't have imagined.
For instance in
retail, Document AI
is being applied
by our customers
to analyze customer feedback
and process store manager
feedback to optimize
the supply chain
and build better
products for customers.
Our financial
services customers are
using Document AI to cut
mortgage processing times
and analyze volumes of
different document types
that are typical to loan
origination process.
Within health care
claims Document AI
is applied to cut
critical time lines
and analyze claims much faster.
Media and
entertainment companies
are using Document AI to
build recommendation engines
and analyze comments and
build these feedback systems.
Within industrial use
cases, Document AI to
is used to analyze highly
technical manuals and site
assessment documents.
And in some cases, analyze
archives of documents
that are over 100 years old.
One company that has reimagined
their documents strategy
by leveraging Document AI is
the industry leading market
services provider Mr. Cooper.
They're challenged to manage
many domain specific mortgage
document types and
have classified
over 100 million pages.
They have trained over 130
mortgage document labels
and achieved over 92%
accuracy in classifications.
Using Document AI, they
trust that their content
can be accurately classified.
Another company that has
leveraged Document AI,
specifically, a custom Document
AI suite a classification
and extraction is DocuSign.
DocuSign has trained millions of
document types using our custom
Document AI models and
have been able to build
an accurate
auto-tagging system that
can enable their
customers to auto
fill some of the key
fields that are highlighted
in yellow on the screen.
Here's an example of
the tagged W-9 form.
It has been auto-tagged
using Document AI.
Document AI can also be applied
to various insurance claims use
cases.
A large US-based
insurance provider
has been able to
leverage Document AI
to achieve over 74% reduction in
claim processing and insurance
settlement time.
The accuracy of our
models has been over 81%.
Another large US-based
financial services company
has been able to
achieve over 97.8%
accuracy using Document
AI to analyze over
350 documents per minute.
With that we are very excited
to release some new updates
to Document AI today.
Mortgage packages
have historically
been a very complex
and document intensive
workflow in our economy.
Now these mortgage packages
can be an ideal use
case for Document AI.
Why?
Mortgage packages are
of very high volume.
They're a mix of
structured, semi-structured,
and unstructured content.
There is a lot of content
validation requirements
on these mortgage packages.
And the same mortgage package
is analyzed over and over again
within origination,
securitization, and servicing.
And sometimes multiple
business units
within the same
financial institution
process income and asset
documents multiple times,
leading to a lot
of inefficiencies.
Once the mortgage package is
converted into structured data,
it can be fed into multiple
downstream analytical and
operational workflows.
We at Google have
identified with our partners
and customers, various
mortgage document types that
fit into a typical
origination workflow
and bucketed into various
high value use cases.
One of our first focus areas is
the income and asset document
bucket.
I'm excited to introduce the
Lending Document AI solution.
This is a bundle of specialized
models focused on document
types used in mortgage lending.
In a nutshell, using
Lending Document AI,
a loan package can be
converted into structured data
by applying specialized DocAI
models built for various income
and asset document types,
such as W-2s, tax forms, bank
statements, and pay stubs.
I am also excited to
introduce a second Document AI
solution called Procure
to Pay Document AI.
Document AI for Procure
to Pay helps enterprises
automate one of their
highest volume and highest
value business processes,
the procurement cycle.
We provide a group
of AI powered parsers
starting with invoices and
receipts that take documents
in a variety of formats and
return clearly structured data.
Earlier this year, we use
the power of Document AI
to help in response to COVID-19.
We developed the PPP
Lending AI Solution
to help lenders
accelerate and automate
processing loan applications
for the Paycheck Protection
Program.
The Document AI PPP parser API
made it possible for lenders
to handle the large intake
volumes of PPP loan requests
by using AI to
extract information
from their loan documents
submitted by applicants.
Here are some of
the key document
types supported by our PPP
commercial lending Document AI.
Document AI is also used
to bring normalization
to ID and passport documents.
With that I'd love to hand over
to my colleague, Lewis Liu,
to talk about some technologies
we use under the hood.
LEWIS LIU: Thank you, Sudheera.
Now let's see Document
AI in action with a demo.
First we will try
to parse it in ways.
The image you saw
on the left, there
is a lot of content in it.
You could see multiple
addresses, different dates,
and many other detail
in the tabular format.
Then we will make
this even harder.
It is a camera captured
image of a W-2 form.
It is wine stained and
the image is highly skewed
and a lot of paper folds.
First, we upload this invoice
to the invoice parser.
Within seconds, you can see the
extracted entity nicely mapped
to a well defined schema.
This is very
powerful because you
don't have to maintain any rule
based mapping layer or any post
processing scripts.
And this also make value
normalization to be possible.
Within the same UI, you
could also inspect and review
the key value pair and
table extraction results.
These outputs are
handy and useful
if you need to apply additional
processing or data mining.
Having seen this on
the UI, now let's
run our W-2 form through
the command line.
This is how production system
integrate with Document AI.
This is the highly distorted
W-2 form we saw earlier.
What we can do is we send this
image through our Lending Doc
AI endpoint and load the
output into a BigQuery table
as a data sync.
With BigQuery, you could
perform more and advanced data
analytics, or just
like us, simply
look at the data in
the tabular format.
If we compare the
result side by side,
we actually extracted
values from the form
with high accuracy
and confidence.
Let's take a look
at a few of them.
SSN, Social Security Number, all
nine digits match the document,
even though hyphens are
in the original field.
Employer identification
number is also correct.
And a more challenging
case, the employer name
and address on row number
six, the entire cell
also extracted 100% correct.
Getting data extracted
from these two documents
is no easy task.
Let me show you one of the
state-of-the-arts model we have
built at Google.
Unlike classic NLP tasks,
document like invoices,
do not contain natural
language as you
might find in regular
sentences and paragraphs.
Data here is often
presented in tables.
In addition, many documents have
multiple pages, varying numbers
of sections, and have a variety
of layouts and formatting clues
to organize those informations.
An understanding of
two dimensional layout
of the text on the
page is the key
to understanding such documents.
Early this year, we publish a
new state-of-the-art research
paper on extracting data
from templatic documents.
This technique is combined
with many things we learned
and used from building optimal
natural language entity
extraction models to better
understand receipts, bills,
insurance quotes, and et cetera.
If you're interested in
learning more on this topic,
I encourage you to take
a look at this paper.
Many of our customers asks
about what's coming for DocAI.
Let me now give you a sneak
peek into the new Document AI
Portal.
It's a one stop shop where you
can create, view, and manage
everything needed to solve
your own business document
challenges.
This also includes a new
processor library, a gallery
of specialized parsers, such
as invoice parser, 941 form
parser, or deny parser.
Apart from the specialized
ones, the library
will also host
other tools like OCR
and form parser
to help you better
in your standard documents.
Introducing another new feature
in Document AI, human review.
An integrated
experience to give you
full confidence on accuracy and
accountability of the model,
helping you meet your regulatory
and compliance requirements,
as well.
Taking a deeper look at the
human review configuration
panel, you will be able to
choose different validation
methods and labeler options.
If you already have
an in-house workforce,
or are using an existing
BPO, or are completely
new to human review in
your AI ML workflow,
we have an option for you.
We are very excited
to see what you'll
be building with our new
DocAI interface and with that,
I'm handing this
back to Sudheera.
SUDHEERA VANGURI:
Thank you, Lewis.
To wrap up, if you think
you have a great use
case for Document AI,
I'd like to encourage
you to identify and
prioritize workflows
that will benefit the most.
Here are a few key resources.
You can find out
more on our website,
or reach out to our
partners who are
familiar with our technologies
to stitch a custom
solution for your needs.
We hope you are as excited
as we are to apply Document
AI to your business today.
Thank you.